un jour Denis boide merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes sénateur
socialiste du Gard membre du groupe
d'études agricultures et alimentation au
Sénat et Quentin Le Guillou bonjour
merci d'être là vous êtes secrétaire
général adjoint des jeunes agriculteurs
on va bien sûr parler avec vous pendant
une demi-heure des enjeux des défis de
l'agriculture mais d'abord Quentin Le
Guillou on l'a vu dessin depuis samedi
c'est le retour en masse des Français
dans ce salon de l'agriculture ça met du
baume au coeur des agriculteurs
oui ça fait du bien de voir autant de
monde c'est vrai que samedi ça a été une
journée comme ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu c'est un avant covid on a
l'impression de renaître un petit peu
tout ça l'année dernière c'était à demi
teinte les gens ont hésité un peu à
revenir sont revenus et là cette année
le samedi le premier jour était vraiment
chargé chargé énormément de monde dans
les allées partout dans tous les halls
donc c'est vrai que ça fait du bien on
s'en soutenu encore un petit peu
Denis Bret c'est important vous
connaissez bien ce milieu vous êtes
sénateur mais vous étiez éviticulteur
c'est important quand on est agriculteur
exploitant agricole ce lien avec les
Français cette rencontre ce rendez-vous
annuel c'est très important parce que
quand on voit l'image qu'on les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui avaient la vie
bachine etc etc on voit comme toi des
visiteurs qui sont là et qui puissent
qui sont au contact des agriculteurs qui
sont au contact des animaux et ça permet
de faire un petit peu on dirait une
communication positive ce métier
d'agriculteur qui est un métier où comme
il est difficile d'ailleurs j'étais moi
à l'époque il y a si longtemps que ça
d'ailleurs président du conseil
départemental du Gard et j'avais demandé
à ce qu'on vienne au salon de
l'agriculture justement pour faire
découvrir nos produits et pour faire un
petit peu la mise en valeur de ce
département
on va évidemment parler de tous les
enjeux de l'agriculture ce salon de
l'agriculture c'est le rendez-vous des
Français mais c'est aussi le rendez-vous
des politiques et après Emmanuel Macron
qui a passé de très longues heures
samedi dans les allées du salon c'est au
tour d'Elizabeth borne d'arpenter ses
allées aujourd'hui et Audrey elle sera
là toute la journée elle aussi oui et ce
sera ça toute première visite avec sa
casquette de Première ministre une
déambulation placée sous le signe des
territoires puisque elle commencera par
le hall des Outre-mer avant de
poursuivre par celui des régions région
Normandie notamment avant une séquence
sportive devant la mascotte du salon la
vache ovalle nous dit-on du côté de son
entourage une visite qui se veut
complémentaire à celle du président nous
expliquons à Matignon Elizabeth borne
devrait détailler les annonces faites
par le président samedi notamment en
matière d'adaptation au changement
climatique elle devrait aussi présenter
un grand plan de recherche
d'alternatives aux produits
phytosanitaires qui devrait être retirés
prochainement du marché avec un soutien
financier de l'État à ses recherches la
première ministre prévoit aussi
d'évoquer la crise des énergies bien sûr
et la crise de la filière bio peut être
au moment du déjeuner qu'elle prendra
avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales vous le voyez un programme
chargé qui commence par le hall des
Outre-mer des 10 heures
coucou Audrey on vous retrouve
évidemment un petit peu plus cas un
petit peu plus tard quand on vous
attendez beaucoup de ces visites de
politiques est-ce que c'est utile c'est
l'occasion de faire passer un message de
faire avancer vos dossiers aussi c'est
toujours un petit peu le rendez-vous de
l'année toute l'année on travaille bien
sûr avec les politiques de tout bord
pour avancer pour discuter là on est
actuellement sur adaptation changement
climatique et aussi quand même le point
fort et et c'est ensemble qu'on va
pouvoir avancer donc bien sûr là c'est
un petit peu la semaine de l'agriculture
allez on se pose tous pendant une
semaine on discute tous ensemble on
essaie d'avancer les les problématiques
et des solutions et puis on va voir ce
qui va en sortir mais c'est vrai qu'on
en attend toujours on va dire de grandes
choses on va parler de la visite salle
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a passé plus de 12
heures ici samedi est-ce qu'il a répondu
aux attentes des agriculteurs selon vos
données
je pense qu'il faut effectivement qu'on
travaille qu'on travaille dès maintenant
parce
on va dire qui montre au moins un
minimum le soutien au monde agricole je
pense qu'aujourd'hui monsieur Macron l'a
prouvé encore samedi à venir sur le
salon à pouvoir nous rencontrer discuter
avec nous voilà je pense que il nous
oublie pas il est avec nous le
gouvernement on le sent qu'ils sont
quand même dans notre coté maintenant
bah c'est c'est toutes les interdictions
les problèmes climatiques qu'on a plus
les surcharges sur les exploitations les
les crises électriques et autres qu'on a
eu sur les coûts énergétiques font aussi
impacter les exploitations donc en fait
c'est un cumul qui aujourd'hui peuvent
créer un petit peu leur ras-le-bol dans
certaines exploitations agricoles donc
bon voilà avec le gouvernement on a on
arrive à discuter je pense que
maintenant il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver de la vision long terme sur
l'accompagnement de ces exploitations là
les exploitations qui sont en crise que
ça soit dans l'arbot dans le Vitis en
grand culture voilà on a des
interdictions il y a des aléas
climatiques bon bah voilà il faut
comment pallier tout ça comment avancer
ensemble je pense qu'on le débat est
ouvert maintenant il faut arriver
ensemble à avancer l'un des grands défis
de l'agriculture française et l'un des
grands thèmes de ce salon c'est la
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
est-ce que la France a aujourd'hui la
capacité et les moyens d'assurer sa
souveraineté alimentaire et de nourrir
sa population non mais comme le crime le
disait notre collègue culture je pense
qu'il y a c'est le fond du problème
quand on regarde par exemple l'élevage
sur voir des seins il y a pas si
longtemps que ça le poulet
20% de la production de poulet en France
tout le reste ça se paraît important
quand on regarde le commerce le commerce
extérieur on est le deuxième exportateur
derrière la
vidéo on a quand même l'agriculture
quand on veut effectivement il faut pas
que il faut que l'administration
comprenne aussi que un certain nombre de
règles que devrait être un petit peu
alléger une simplicité dans les
procédures parce qu'on passe internet
finit à faire des procédures qui dans
son état certain que tout le monde
regarde d'ailleurs je pense qu'il y a
des il y a des choses qu'on peut qu'on
peut faire sans pour autant
révolutionner complètement mais c'est
vrai que cette souveraineté alimentaire
on en a besoin aujourd'hui parce que on
constate quand même que on a trop de
produits importés
les agriculteurs peuvent assurer la
souveraineté alimentaire aujourd'hui on
peut foutu d'un corps donné les moyens
et effectivement par un certain nombre
de charges qui leur incombe l'énergie
vous disiez il y a deux minutes
l'énergie mettez-vous à quelqu'un à la
place de quelqu'un qui produit des
fruits et légumes qui ont un frigo qui a
un compteur de 48 kva ou je ne sais
combien il paye l'électricité un prix
très élevé les rotations d'écoute est
importante il a des marges qui sont
minimes comment voulez-vous que c'est en
sorte sur l'accompagnement comment ça se
traduit c'est important cette question
de l'énergie on en parle évidemment
depuis plusieurs mois comment ça se
traduit concrètement pour les
agriculteurs qu'est-ce que ça implique
pour vous cette augmentation des prix de
l'énergie
ça implique une multitude de choses
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'était
il y a encore un an c'était peut-être
pas forcément le poste de charge le plus
élevé sur exploitation aujourd'hui c'est
presque si c'est pas l'unique poste le
plus élevé les coûts énergétiques sur
les frigos sur les transformations
donc aujourd'hui il faut réussir à
concilier
cette hausse de charge champ force sans
forcément l'impact au consommateurs
l'idée oui ok bon bah on a un coût
énergétique qui est là bon bah on va
peut-être essayer de remonter exemple
sur les pommes de terre ou sur les ou
sur les fruits et légumes on va essayer
de remonter un petit peu le prix pour
compenser un petit peu le coût
énergétique sauf que qui sait
malheureusement à la fin qui a impacté
c'est le consommateur et des fois
l'agriculteur lui de cette augmentation
n'envoie qu'une petite partie donc
aujourd'hui il faut réussir à tous se
mettre autour d'une table dire ok on est
impacté qui est impacté comment on va
l'impacter et et voir comment on peut
essayer d'évoluer ce prix pour qu'il
aille jusqu'au consommateur sans
forcément trop taper dans la poche du
consommateur parce que c'est toujours
toujours le consommateur et justement
l'une des questions c'est la
rémunération aussi un des agriculteurs
alors samedi lors de sa visite au salon
Emmanuel Macron a lancé un message au
distributeur on écoute
donc notre alimentation nous en
préserver la valeur pour que nos
producteurs nos agriculteurs vivent de
ce revenu ensuite il faut que avec nos
distributions nous fassent très
attention parce qu'il y a certaines
marques qui sont pas celles produits par
nos agriculteurs sont souvent des
marques de distributeurs qui ont une
envolée des prix qui touche le
portefeuille de nos
consommateurs donc faut faire cet effort
faut être très vigilant mais là on a
besoin d'un effort collectif d'un
engagement c'est ça ce que je demande
aussi à nos distributeurs aujourd'hui
cette participer à l'effort ils font des
bénéfices des profits j'en suis heureux
pour eux et leurs salariés j'espère
qu'ils le redistribue mais dans ce
moment-là on peut pas demander un effort
à nos producteurs parce que nos
agriculteurs payent plus cher l'énergie
plus cher les intrants divers produits
et on a besoin de garantir leurs revenus
il a eu les bons mots Emmanuel Macron
Quentin Le Guillou cet appel est
suffisant pour vous
déjà c'est dit déjà c'est dit ça remet
un petit peu les choses quand c'est le
président de la République qui dit ça
qui qui annonce ça bon voilà déjà ça
repose un petit peu les bases maintenant
il y a du il y a du travail il y a des
lois qui existent les lois EGA qui ont
été qui ont été mises en place et qu'il
faut encore accentuer et sur les
étagères tout à fait voilà bah
maintenant je pense qu'on peut encore
essayer d'améliorer tout le système les
distributeurs avec leur MDD les marques
distributeurs peuvent aussi essayer de
mieux jouer le jeu face face au prix et
la loi égali mais elles avaient pour but
de rééquilibrer les relations entre
distributeurs et agriculteurs ça a été
le cas
aujourd'hui on a on a une partie des
agriculteurs qui ont pas encore
forcément confiance pour aller vers ces
contrats nous on leur dit allez-y si
vous voulez un prix assuré sur du long
terme il faut aller chercher ses
contrats donc aujourd'hui on a du mal
quand on a des agriculteurs qui nous
disent un problème de rémunération mais
je veux pas signer le contrat bon alors
faut discuter qu'est-ce que tu veux
maintenant on essaye de dire à ces
agriculteurs là une fois que tu as fait
ton contrat voyons en face les grandes
distributions les MDD et toutes les
autres marques qu'est-ce qu'elles
sortent on essaye de demander des
chiffres moi j'aimerais bien avoir une
feuille avec qui vend combien qui prend
combien qui à quoi et aujourd'hui tout
le monde est très flou sauf que il y a
un manque de transparence encore qui est
là aujourd'hui on connaît à peu près le
prix que le producteur va vendre son
produit et on voit le prix final
consommateur
où va l'entre-deux demain si on est
capable de m'expliquer ok le coût
énergétique le transport il y a pas de
problème il y a pas de souci sauf qu'on
n'est pas capable de nous le fournir si
demain on a des chiffres bien détaillés
convenablement on va pouvoir voir un peu
plus ces choses il y a des prix qui
commence à sortir le gouvernement a des
chiffres aussi un petit peu donc
j'espère qu'on va remettre un petit peu
tout le monde dans le droit chemin et
qu'on va pouvoir aller et tout le monde
faire des efforts je pense qu'on est
tous capables de faire des efforts il y
a encore un manque de transparence il y
a encore des efforts à faire Denis bots
avec la ligne 3 qui était quand même une
progression et un petit peu plus de
comment dirais de responsabilité des uns
et des autres dans le cadre cette loi
interdit de vendre à perte etc etc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ce que nous avons
besoin c'est le respect de ces règles
parce que parfois ces règles sont bonnes
ou pas je les ai d'ailleurs voté c'est
pas un problème pour nous mais pour
autant faut-il encore qu'elle soit
appliquée et qu'elle permettent de jus
de se rémunération aux agriculteurs
parce que le problème il est où le
problème c'est que si on veut des
agriculteurs qui puissent vivre de leur
exploitation vivre de leur vivre sur
leur propre terrain de leur propre
région on a besoin d'une rémunération
qui soit à la hauteur du travail qu'il
fournissent et c'est bien là où il y a
tout le problème d'ailleurs mais qui ne
les applique pas aujourd'hui qui ne joue
pas le jeu sont les distributeurs qui
jouent pas je suis un petit peu ce qu'on
nous a dit entre le prix producteur et
le prix du consommateur où on peut pas
effectivement en permanence augmenter le
prix le prix à l'arrivée
il y a peut-être une marge de leur
milieu qui te faut regarder il faut
arrêter aussi en tout cas
qui vers le bas c'est aussi ça que vous
demandez aux grandes chiens aux grandes
enseignes de la distribution bah bien
sûr parce que quand les distributeurs
vont enchaîner les promotions casser les
prix derrière on sait clairement que il
y a pas de vente à perte enfin du moins
pour une peuvent essayer une fois deux
fois mais des entreprises qui vont à
perte souvent de vivre pas très
longtemps donc je vu les capacités
aujourd'hui de ces grands distributions
là et de CPME ces grandes distributions
plutôt sont capables aujourd'hui je
pense de aller négocier les prix donc il
y a des prix encore qui sont cassés
descendus et du coup je pense acheter
moins cher au producteurs ou du moins à
un prix on va dire peut-être à juste
équilibre et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a encore des
exploitations qui sont dans la
difficulté qui et on est quand même en
2023 ça fait quand même des années qu'on
entend ce problème là
le prix est légèrement vendu de plus en
plus cher tous les ans sauf que les
charges suivent aussi derrière et voilà
on n'a pas encore cette bascule qu'on a
réussi à faire entre le prix de vente et
les charges qui seraient intéressante et
rémunératrice pour l'agriculture
si on peut rajouter aussi la concurrence
internationale notamment sur les fruits
et légumes avec des fruits et des
légumes qui arrivent de pays parfois
européenne à des prix des fiancés toute
conférence ou ils ne sont pas confrontés
au même difficultés en terme de charge
de fonctionnement que ce que sont
français internationale cette
concurrence
sous le sens pour l'agriculture
française elle est au sein de l'Union
européenne
mais aussi au sein de l'Union européenne
comme final il y a un problème de
différence de norme
des distorsions entre les différents
pays de l'Union européenne Quentin les
Guilloux oui bah au sein même de
l'Europe sans même de l'Europe on le
sait il y a des pays où des produits
vont être peut-être autorisés alors
qu'en France ne sont plus et à l'inverse
peut-être
du coup le coup de main d'oeuvre aussi
aujourd'hui on est tous dans l'Europe
nous aujourd'hui pour payer un salarié
1500 je vais en donner 1500 donc je vais
donner 3000 par mois pour mon salarié
sur des pays peut-être plus sur l'est de
la France bon bah c'est des charges qui
ont quand même diminué pour faire le
même le même travail sur le même temps
horaire ils vont peut-être sortir que 8
900 ou 1000 euros par mois
c'est un plus voilà c'est les charges le
coût énergétique le
l'énorme en plus qu'on peut avoir et du
coup le tout cumulé fait que en France
certes on a peut-être même sûrement
c'est même sûr des produits de qualité
sauf qu'ils on n'arrive pas à les
valoriser un petit peu au juste on
essaye plutôt de s'aligner sur un prix
monde et Europe sauf que on joue pas
malheureusement dans la même cour avec
tout le monde
au début de cette émission c'est le
réchauffement climatique les
conséquences du climat et notamment en
ce moment cette sécheresse hivernale
record plus de 30 jours sans pluie
Audrey vous êtes dans les allées du
salon avec des agriculteurs et à vos
côtés Cécile dukouloumier éleveuse de
vache de race au bras en Lozère et la
sécheresse n'est pas sans conséquence
sur son troupeau oui on a l'impression
que la sécheresse ne touche que les
cultivateurs mais elles touchent aussi
les éleveurs Cécile du Coulombier donc
vous êtes éleveuse de Raches de race
Aubrac pas facile à dire alors justement
en quoi la sécheresse touche votre
troupeau il faut savoir que nous dans
notre élevage Aubrac sur le plateau de
l'Aubrac en fait la ressource principale
pour nous et nos animaux c'est l'herbe
orbe c'est un végétal même qu'elle soit
naturelle elle a besoin d'eau surtout à
certaines périodes puisque la vache va à
la fois se nourrir sur sur place en
allant paturer mais aussi l'hiver va
aussi se nourrir d'herbe donc on a on a
besoin d'une bonne pousse de l'herbe en
fait à plusieurs fois dans l'année donc
si le manque on en vient à se poser
plein de questions sur la façon de
nourrir nos vaches est-ce qu'il existe
des alternatives alors c'est compliqué
il y en a mais elles sont compliquées
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que tout son si l'herbe de pousse pas là
où les vaches sont vous pouvez pas
emmener les vaches ailleurs se nourrir
dans un supermarché ou aller chez un
voisin donc il faut qu'elles aient
l'horaire qui repoussent et donc ça
c'est très compliqué là et la solution
qu'on fait à ce moment-là c'est de leur
donner du foin donc d'amener l'herbe
sèche qu'on aura pu stocker sauf que ce
foin quand il vient à manquer il faut
l'acheter et le problème c'est que
souvent quand vous manquez vous de foin
c'est que vous allez manquer d'herbe et
souvent le le la région autour commence
à en manquer il y a eu la sécheresse
aussi et si comme là ces années si ça ça
se passe au niveau national en fait le
foin commence à prendre à des prix très
très élevés parce qu'il se fait un cours
du foin donc c'est c'est difficile
économiquement vous pouvez pas vous
permettre d'acheter plusieurs camions de
fonds justement l'hiver 2023 c'est plus
de 100 jours sans pluie est-ce que ça
vous inquiète alors oui on se dit qu'on
a encore une petite espérance c'est le
printemps si il pleut rapidement la
végétation va pas encore le prendre trop
ça va les sols vont pouvoir garder de
l'eau et au printemps ça va pousser si
ça pousse pas on va se rendre il va
falloir trouver des solutions qui sont
encore une autre réponse à ça c'est
finalement avoir moins de hache pour que
les vaches qui restent trouvent à la
fois pâturage foin et eau là où on va
les élever le problème après c'est que
vous voyez bien que sur diminue le
nombre de vaches on diminue aussi le
revenu des éleveurs parce que
aujourd'hui on n'est pas gros par
plaisir parfois on augmente parce que le
nombre enfin la vente des produits qu'on
a ne suffit pas donc il faut en avoir un
petit peu plus pour toujours garder le
même revenu vous aviez un petit message
à faire passer justement
en fait alors la difficulté aujourd'hui
ce serait que on soit sur le enfin on
peut pas non plus demander des aides
sans arrêt c'est pas tout à fait ça le
principe mais on se dit qu'il va falloir
que du coup on trouve une alternative à
ça ce sera un autre solution c'est qu'on
sache que le prix d'un de la viande
qu'on va fournir elle a un coût en fait
elle a un prix elle a elle correspond à
du temps passé et il faut que les gens
se rendent compte du vrai prix que ça
peut coûter d'aller acheter une viande
nourrie à l'herbe et j'insiste sur ça
parce que nous on est très fier de notre
élevage les vaches sortent elles mangent
de l'herbe voilà vous le voyez un
message aux consommateur le prix des
choses le prix de la bonne viande merci
beaucoup voilà Oriane la sécheresse qui
a de nombreuses problématiques même sur
l'élevage merci merci beaucoup Audrey
évidemment à tout à l'heure on a entendu
cet éleveuse Denis la sécheresse elle
n'a pas que des conséquences sur les
cultivateurs elle a des conséquences sur
l'ensemble du monde agricole quel que
soit les productions de la sécheresse le
réchauffement climatique on en
aujourd'hui on avait le président de la
République en a parlé la salle de
l'occasion de sa visite mais c'est pas
un phénomène nouveau et tant mieux si
nous dit que il va prendre des mesures
et des mesures énergies et des mesures
efficaces parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin c'est
premièrement peut-être revoir sur
certains secteurs nos cultures peut-être
qu'on pourra pas faire cultiver tout et
n'importe quoi partout deuxièmement il
faut un plan d'irrigation parce que le
problème de l'eau c'est l'eau aussi pour
nos villages et nos vies et nos villages
pour moi le problème de de l'irrigation
des cultures agricoles il nous faut
aller vers une riviation raisonnée une
rivisation raisonnable je vois chez moi
un arboriculture ou en viticulture
notamment il faut aller vers du
goutte-à-goutte je regarde ce qu'on fait
au niveau de chez moi il y a vous savez
chez moi il y a dans le Gard où il y a
trop d'eau et auquel cas c'est des
inondations dévastatrices et voilà et ça
part tout de suite heureux d'être tout
de suite à la mer ou alors manque d'eau
et auquel cas et ben c'est des grandes
difficultés y compris pour certains
villages dans ce monde département qui
n'ont pas eu d'autres cet été donc on a
besoin de quoi faire des retenues
colinéaires
nous avons besoin de ça il y a soit
envers les années 60
je crois que ce canal aujourd'hui ce
qu'il a besoin c'est de se développer
diriger dans l'ensemble de ce
département en eau potable bien sûr mais
aussi à nous pour nous permettre de
l'agriculture de rester sur place et on
a les dossier notre jour au Sénat il y a
quelques semaines maintenant
je crois qu'il nous faut rechercher
aussi des cultures qui soient comment
dirais-je le besoin de moins d'eau des
portes grèves pour les vignes qui aille
chercher la l'humidité bien pour vivre
au fond des techniques d'arrosage qui
soient revues à la un petit peu à la
baisse etc etc c'est un travail
collectif est-ce qu'il faut des retenues
d'eau est-ce qu'il faut des méga
bassines
c'est un sujet qui est très polémique
commençons par faire des choses qui sont
simples les retenues colinéaires il n'y
a pas grand chose à faire et ça permet
de rester des agriculteurs de rester sur
place après effectivement voyons comment
on peut avec cette eau qui tombe un
abondance pendant des périodes notamment
au mois de septembre avec cette eau qui
tombe en abondance comment on fait pour
la conserver et s'en servir au contraire
l'été
Quentin le Guillon sur ses retenues
d'eau est-ce que les méga bassines on
sait que c'est un sujet polémique est-ce
que pour vous ça va devenir nécessaire
pour les agriculteurs
sur les retenues colinéaires je suis
entièrement d'accord sur les retenues
d'eau aussi pour moi aujourd'hui quand
on voit la quantité d'eau là on se
plaint qu'on a une sécheresse ça fait
moi sur l'exploitation ça fait 35 jours
que dernière pluie c'était autour du 20
janvier j'ai eu un millimètre milieu de
semaine dernière donc c'est rien ça nous
a juste mouillé le sol ce qu'on craint
c'est que dans 15 jours trois semaines
d'un coup il va tomber 50 60 mm d'un
coup fort le seul va en profiter mais
sauf que ça va tomber peut-être en 5-6
heures il y a une partie qui va ruseler
qui va prendre le fossé la rivière et
moi c'est l'heure la scène et ça part
ensuite sur dans l'océan donc ça va pas
recharger ça va aller trop vite pour le
sol sauf si j'espère dès qu'on arrive à
partir sur des petites pluies longues et
efficaces pas de problème sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on a des aléas des pluies
qui nous tombe forte d'un coup qu'on
n'arrive pas à récupérer pas à stocker
pour moi je pense que avec le varen de
l'eau qui avait été travaillé il y a 2
ans aujourd'hui on doit être dans la
capacité d'essayer de pouvoir au moins
essayer de retenir un petit peu ces eaux
là de les stocker pour pouvoir les
utiliser à bonifier science et bon
escient dans dans les parcelles
agricoles on a aujourd'hui une quantité
d'eau qui est stockée en France d'autres
pluies c'est ridicule c'est minime donc
alors que à l'opposé on a des parents on
a des chasses d'eau à 8 litres à chaque
fois qu'on va tirer plusieurs fois dans
la journée d'eau potable et on n'est pas
capable aujourd'hui de faire des
retenues d'eau capable de pouvoir
peut-être tenir une bonne partie de
l'année les cultures et notamment bah
sur les fourrages où on entendait tout à
l'heure madame parler sur sur son foin
mais c'est problématique aujourd'hui le
sud de la France se coucher en
sécheresse depuis quasiment un an et
demi le Nord on y est on a les herbes on
voit les les herbes un peu partout vous
prenez votre voiture vous voyez les
talus qui sont d'une couleur jaune sèche
si on continue comme ça ça va être
problématique pour pour les pour les
mois à venir et puis notamment pour
l'éleveur je et toutes les autres
cultures et cette question du recyclage
et de la réutilisation de l'eau elle est
importante Denis est-ce qu'il faut
revoir la loi sur l'eau est-ce qu'il
faut permettre de mieux recycler de
mieux réutiliser cette eau il faut
surtout revoir le règlementation il y a
l'eau de station d'épuration qu'on peut
très bien traiter un petit peu plus et
qui peut permettre de l'arrosage c'est
des quantités
formidable je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on a besoin c'est effectivement
comment dirais que le Président de la
République se les a d'annonce qu'il a
faite soit concrète et se retranscrisent
par ses administrations parce que
parfois on est un petit peu sur des
administrations qui sont réticentes et
aujourd'hui c'est le temps c'est le
temps c'est qu'en fait l'urgence on y
est en fait malheureusement on y est
alors on peut avoir une sur
on va passer à un autre sujet et en même
temps c'est un sujet qui vous concerne
particulièrement Denis boîte puisque
vous étiez viticulteur la viticulture
vous le disait tout à l'heure c'est le
deuxième secteur qui contribue
positivement à la balance commerciale de
la France après l'aéronautique et
pourtant vous n'êtes pas épargné par les
crises dans le secteur de la vie de
culture alors c'est particulier parce
que la baisse de la consommation en
France de 2,5% par an donc c'est quand
même pas neutre sur 15 millions
d'hectolitres en France on a eu une
année 2021 avec un gel catastrophique
qui a touché toutes les régions donc on
avait une petite récolte en 2021 on a
une récolte 2022 qui n'est pas une
récolteceptionnelle et pour autant on a
des stocks des années antérieures et
notamment le Bordelais qui aujourd'hui
demande de la distillation de crise
parce qu'il y a un problème de
distillation il faut apurer le marché
donc je crois que le Président de la
République notamment le ministre de
l'Agriculture si si penché sur le
dossier et on va vers une distillation
qui serait importante c'est tout
simplement
c'est une bonne chose
200 millions d'euros pour arriver à
écouler le marché et il en faut plus
quand un Yu-Gi-Oh
c'est c'est toujours toujours le même
problème c'est bien sûr oui il en faut
plus pour pour pouvoir essayer de
d'endiguer le problème malheureusement
en fait c'est que pour beaucoup c'est du
travail qui a pas été fait en amont
c'est des choses qui ont déjà dû être
réfléchies c'est des remises en question
en fait sans cesse sur les exploitations
dans le monde agricole et je pense qu'on
a des acquis des fois on profite de ces
acquis on est content et au bout de
quelques années et quelques décennies on
peut perdre cette facilité qu'on a eu
cette réussite des fois qu'on a eu et si
il y a pas de remise en question
l'agriculture une exploitation
électrique
aujourd'hui c'est un message à tout le
monde aujourd'hui on est chef
d'entreprise un chef d'entreprise doit
sans cesse se remettre en question sur
son entreprise à un agriculteur c'est la
même il faut se remettre en question
voir sur du long terme voir les visions
on a un changement climatique qui est là
on a des températures qui augmentent
donc je pense que chaque exploitation va
être amené à faire des changements
comment on va aller travailler ensemble
avec quel argent quel comment tout ça on
va pouvoir mettre en place je pense
qu'on va pouvoir aussi travailler
ensemble maintenant il faut il faut
sortir un petit peu de notre de nos de
nos acquis de notre bien-être et aller
de l'avant tous ensemble on est sur un
problème ce n'est pas sur un problème
conjonctuel on est sur un problème
structurel aujourd'hui il nous faut
arracher quelques vecteurs de vigne en
France pour arriver à avoir une
production qui a été corresponde à la à
la réalité il y a une deuxième chose
qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il faut que
notamment le ministre de l'Agriculture
peut y faire on a des crédits qui sont
affectés à France agrimaire qui
permettent aux agriculteurs de
d'exporter parce que nous sommes dans
l'exportation de de veines de spirituel
dans ce pays ces crédits sont tellement
compliqués à obtenir qu'il nous faut là
une simplification des procédures
effectivement on pourra là aussi avoir
de la progression sur le sur les sports
il va vous répondre dans quelques
instants un dernier mot puisque
évidemment l'autre secteur qui est
touché c'est la filière betterave la
filière betterave sucrière suite à une
décision de la Cour la justice de
l'Union européenne le gouvernement a dû
cesser les dérogations pour
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes mais
le mieux de l'agriculture assure que les
producteurs seront indemnisés en cas de
jaunissent vous êtes rassurés
oui bon c'est toujours des des
subventions encore encore encore encore
en plus tant mieux c'est très bien on va
pouvoir essayer de passer cette année
maintenant l'année prochaine on fait
quoi on recommence c'est encore des
subventions non je pense que il y a un
moment c'est pareil c'est ce que comme
on disait pour la crise il faut se poser
tout de suite en se disant on va avoir
des des produits qui vont disparaître
c'est sûr dans 5 10 ans comment on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on a en face pour les
remplacer ou pour du moins les compléter
changer notre méthode qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire sur tout ça donc oui on va
avoir là peut-être une enveloppe qui est
pas encore définie qui va arriver si
l'exploitant si les exploitants sont
touchés
sur les pucerons
malheureusement voilà c'est c'est une
survie et je sais pas si ça va forcément
bien aidé la filière betterave parce que
allez ils vont y aller là cette année
mais pour moi c'est demain c'est l'année
prochaine qu'est-ce qu'on fait et on va
voir ce que vous répondiez l'agriculture
tout de suite puisque il va vous
succéder sur ce plateau merci Denis
Boade et merci beaucoup Quentin Le
Guillou d'avoir été avec nous suite de
notre émission spéciale ici depuis le
salon de l'agriculture et c'est donc
l'heure de notre invité politique c'est
marqué nous qui nous rejoint